foreign
foreign
foreign
hungry
what's next
oh
storm is getting worse
I'll get them ready
mm-hmm
thank you
need help
ready
foreign
I hope fenra got some sleep maybe he'll
be ready to eat when we get home
he is
quite sick dress I know but he was a
little better yesterday
until he wasn't
he keeps eating I'm not giving up on him
hear that yes
is it her
the state is not far
not again get ready
she wouldn't give up that easy would she
she never does stay alert
he's gotta get away from her I'm tired
up there let's see
look out
the trees they're coming down
that was too close
he's coming around again
hold tight protection Stave is near
oh no
yeah
please don't make me do this
try it out
oh yeah yeah
we're three of us Dave
we made it
let us go home
it's Becky Savannah up
huh
I'm sorry I couldn't take the shot I did
not wish you to
keep hoping she'll let it go you saved
her life I killed her son
there is no letting back go
yeah
I guess killing balder really did bring
on femble winter
stop snowing after that day
think it's ever gonna get better
someday
still ahead of us
I got it
foreign
go on girls
foreign
I don't hear him he always says hello
Petraeus Ben rear
you okay boy
it's okay boy
you're okay
I know I missed you too
where's your food still hungry
come on boy
you need to eat
eat
what
too big
there you go
oh boy
Andreas the time draws near
you must prepare yourself
for what
he's still eating he wants to live
he's dying
you're a good boy
oh Brave boy
fast and strong
but you can rest now
okay
I'll be okay
you can let go now
you have to let go
softener
Opera
they sue
so far
it's on
foreign
what
no
it's the middle of the night
light does not stop our enemies
why
what for
training is all we ever do ever
it's not enough
we can't hide forever
time is running out
the prophecies say femble winter leads
to Ragnarok
war is coming
whatever Loki's supposed to be doing
he's supposed to be doing it now
my story doesn't end hiding in these
Woods I should be out there finding out
who I am who Loki is I will not allow
you to pick a fight with gods
I don't want to fight anyone
I just want answers and if those answers
lead to war with Asgard
maybe that's what mother want
what mother wanted
looks like we never will
look
I have a moment alone with fenrir before
I bury him
thank you
well I recognize that dirt expression
anywhere
care to tell me what went wrong
it's gone
oh no
not fenlier
how's the lad taking it
dwell
bury him oh
damn it
all right brother
good night there
foreign
foreign
Kratos
are you joining me
very are you ready
you walk as though Emir himself sits
atop your shoulders
very well girls
fresh kill
at least it didn't suffer hmm
am I to decipher your grunting
tell me your thoughts
a wolf
skill
it is the natural order of things your
words are misguided
we want to help
don't we
no don't
come on
sick wolf we found beyond our Stave
we found his way inside
as I said he would
we should have acted it was not our
concern
nowadays
problem doesn't have to reach our
doorstep for it to be our responsibility
if we have the power to limit the harm
it could cause
we should act
who are we to hide and do nothing we are
not hiding
foreign
gonna make me pick that one up
foreign
this way
very
very
time is running out my love and there is
much to
foreign
he never came back from Daddy and the
Wolf
been some time
you came up before
let's see tracks heading down to the
Frozen River that's most likely where he
did the burying
fast dwindling now
where else could he have gone from here
he crawled through here
foreign
nightmares I dream of the past
almost every night ah the bad old days
in Greece no
it feels like phase
trying to tell me something you don't
mean to say you're talking to ghosts
again brother no
but it is something more than memory
foreign
use your words brother the truck stop
here
and we're not alone
come on
thank you
plastic readers they should not be this
close we should check on the protection
Steve there's a tree up ahead yeah
oh
my God
well you're right The Stave is broken
explains our trespassers what happened
here
brother back there a dead animal a
struggle we must find atreus I between
the Savage beasts and marauding Raiders
he may have sought shelter follow the
trail we'll find him
ah we need our way around
we won't find him this way let's find
that trail of blood
aha feels on the other side if you can
feel the way any idea what could have
made the light wander off we argued he
accuses me of
hiding from Odin yeah only sensible to
keep a low profile at the killing three
of his kin well Reckoning will come
that is why atreus must learn to survive
on his own oh this is about that
prophecy just because the Giants had you
dead on some wall full of otherwise
accurate predictions I do not believe in
prophecies well
good
you believe in Prophecy I'm skeptical by
Nature though we have seen things that
defy explanation So speaking as the
smartest man alive I have no bloody idea
foreign
foreign
all right where's that trail gone
go
back
too many for a scouting party
they must have a camp nearby I know what
you're thinking brother but atreus can
handle himself
you've taught him well so he keeps
telling me
torches and the trail leads into that
cave well we know where we are going I'm
sure we can find a quiet way
are these the Raiders you rescued the
wolves from no
they have not been here long
ER
behind you
the fail goes through here needs deeper
in there will be more
well someone got in the Bear's way
oh
that one's got a swing
good job
another reader to the left
Patrice are you here
the trail leads back out we'll need our
own way up to find it again
perhaps a Chase came here seeking
shelter kept moving when he saw the
Raiders and the bear came battling after
impressive Rampage I'll give it that you
think the bear was chasing the trace
well just as likely the bear was huffed
and a trace was chasing it to help you
know the lad